no no you wouldn't what about starting  the high-speed rail line back to front  as it were in Scotland no I'm not gonna  get into a bargaining game with Alex  Salmond look he's nothing no I'm not you  are if you have any chance of forming a  government you will weren't you know  don't be so presumptuous for six weeks  to go for six weeks to go you don't get  to decide the election result six weeks  before the general if you're important  Jeremy but not that important it's a  brighter water Brian it's a pretty I  don't want to decide no come on you know  there no no no no there is British  people there knows now let me finish the  point you it's a British people you're  suggesting you can get an overall job  lately right absolutely wrong okay right